this program is brought to you by
Teachers College Columbia University
please visit us online at iTunes t.c
Columbia edu
Wow I learned some things today thank
you for the work that you do I believe
we all thank you for the work that you
do good morning the confident director
dr. Barbara Wallace to the featured
keynote speakers come back to yesterday
as doctors and the courts Sachs and
Miller to this morning's plenary dr.
Robert Fullilove into my fellow featured
speaker as I said I learned some things
today thank you and - of course you my
wife and this for me today
preciate you it's really a pleasure to
be amongst notable folk people who are
doing our work they're granting their
accomplishment I'm humbled to be a part
of bringing good information in change
in prospects to the people it's good to
take time to speak to the hearts and
minds those were thinking about change I
bring you greetings from this very
community when this house of sands
greetings from the streets the tenants
project cell body I bring you greetings
from the community that has birthed the
comics I bring you greetings from the
husbands and wives that wait and visit
that conjugating and visit and that we
the president's clueless as to how
broken the unions are I bring you
reading from the children who imagine
their parents to pictures and stories
and there's somebody saying oh my
goodness you look just like your father
bring you greetings from a community
that looks at our minds for answers
answers to questions of health answers
to restore the public trust answers to
the model of life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness
or better yet answers regarding peace
order and good government things like
that that don't seem to exist anymore
and what about essential things things
like housing and employment education
and wellness but I believe that if you
give someone the tools and the
information and you give them the
opportunity they will strive for the bad
life it doesn't matter whether you're in
the general prominent
I think you want a better life if you
have the opportunity you strive for that
so we the lines spend our days in
covering the disenfranchised redirecting
the loss and dismantling the wilderness
that's what the woman is all about with
the wilderness is we've all had
wilderness
for some of us for some of us it's flip
the public exposure of personal traits
our secrets come tumbling down out of
the closet and we apologize for some of
us that wilderness is professional
while our public life stand picturesque
or personal marriages children and
relationships are ravaged with turmoil
in grief but some of us the wilderness
is person while we appear strong we
strategize to develop national and
global missions inside struggle stuff
alcoholism HIV heart disease domestic
violence diabetes influence cancer many
of us are in fact the same relationships
that meet the minds struggle with the
same issues that we demonstrable with
some of the people of Prisons struggling
and what's worse is so we de Mai spend
our days empowering the disenfranchised
redirecting the loss and dismantling
their wilderness the wilderness is
desert like
in this community fault even to cons and
operative elevators dwellings reaching
the 30 stories or the projects there's
about 14 apartments on floor where the
apartments usually have maximum three
bedrooms or so a lot of people living in
those bottoms over a hundred families
for a building averaging about 12
buildings in the public development
running five blocks by one blocking to
mention thousands of people all living
on top of each other in the community
Boston community boards 1011 the
parameters of this on the east side come
out of this building in to your left and
walk that's as far as you can go that's
the East River and after you are that's
where your borders on the south side is
96th Street on the north side is a
hundred the 42nd Street and it's most
westerly border days Whiteside Drive two
blocks away from you
that area to share the city's SLOS that
occasionally there's more people in more
educational deficient professionally not
stupid to even get to and the poorest
areas in it is in this area that New
York State releases approximately 1,000
inmates a month in this block across the
park now let's bring it up for Bronx in
Manhattan rocks the Manhattan to cross
any other bridges the crossing rivers
that one did 35th 155th Street you go
into another far less the Bronx okay
those two boroughs
it's called Metro one the state has that
as a metro and one where parole offices
and that agency supervises inmates there
are 13,000 13,000 people on parole in
that area right now 5,000 around another
wall $5,000 male blacks in 4,000
participants the men are not in their
homes we've already heard that everybody
seems to know that but the system
continues to reproduce that same problem
the men are the most only commodity in
our communities wouldn't it be grand if
they could all work and come home every
night to a wife and family for someone
to ask you how's your day today
well you would give them a success story
the pride of accomplishment it doesn't
matter the level of a job just the fact
that you have one and a story to tell
makes a difference in a man's life work
and being able to provide the man woman
yes
the same muscle on the light on the last
community is the church now I've said
Church and you know to some extent CDs
and people saw it readjusts
themselves in this seats and then when
you mention the church thank you so much
when you mention church one often thinks
about how long is the service going to
be in one of they might say collection
but you know as soon as we find
ourselves in a situation generally
speaking the first thing that you say oh
my god first thing that comes anymore
and you know I'm someone who would know
more I think about its past died we seem
to always end up in the church and even
when we think about our own demise
everybody wants to go to heaven
so we're thinking about churches being
an entity is the most successful
nonprofit standing and it can help
propel your project what you need to do
is to speak to the pastor so that your
project does not affirm his Church's
doctrine and what they want to do for
their people and once would that
compromise look at all the churches look
at all the people just imagine all your
families look at the foundation and the
base one which you can work for this is
the threshold one which is five hundred
minutes five hundred minutes all the
church accountable to stand - doctor -
outreach didn't bring other people into
its confines those
people wore losses not members or
believers 500 apartments with every CBO
mean find the essence of bring their
clients into our events had no charge to
their organizations than the men go home
please
what we do is we feed them we feed them
of course
nervous from the physical nursing
breathless and and loves and then we
give them practical methods and
giveaways that represents where they are
in their experience at that time we
offer workshops at our events workshops
and family spirituality banking child
support spirituality I didn't say that
I'm sorry money management fatherhood
substance abuse and health issues we
tried to speak with them where they are
and we keep them on method on how they
can walk out of our doors with another
frame of mind a new reference under
stalling for a sense of empowerment we
also went to great our job fair for the
last two years we've been having a job
fair at our primary location which is
the pilgrim Cathedral Harlem it's right
located on the new 26 feet between
Finland exactly were able to about 50
jobs over the last two years the
attendance was 150 each year it was just
a wonderful thing and they also got
employed right here at Columbia doing
ground warden maintenance so the the the
community has been very helpful in just
dressing what we're trying to do in
terms of all right again in 2005 we plan
to expand to every bar in the city by
2010 so this being a whole year we're
going to have four events planned for
for the borough's all accepts that nom
and we've been located so for three
churches nonprofits and municipal
locations the Blue Crane five months
500 men's blueprints based on leadership
everyone talks about how to replicate
what we do try to do it again or
something similar
five months planning perseverance people
perfecting and production once again
planning perseverance people perfecting
in production planning believable leader
starting with the end in mind developing
an internal system of stamina you have
to be able to keep up with yourself to
do the work that's required you need to
see the intangible division you are the
visionary you need to be an integral
part of what everyone else doesn't see
yet integrity honesty faith commitment
all those things you need to work on
daily so that they are part of who you
are otherwise you can't give that to
anyone else
once you're strong in it personally
strong in it then you can admit that to
your organization locally we national
and global perseverance consistency
reach results guarantee you do something
every day it becomes a habit it works
for you it works for you as a leader in
war for those who follow you don't hurt
yourself
success takes time so start early stay
late get some rest because there's more
than you tomorrow
people people surrounding us some of the
most committed select from the committee
the most disciplined so that's the most
disciplined the best-equipped teach a
vision teach a vision teach your vision
teach a vision and those who follow with
you
perfecting perfecting is a process it's
not perfection
it's the knack of becoming but in
leading and getting those to follow you
in developing a core within an
organization and a community entity what
we all have a role to be helpful the jaw
responsibility to develop clear systems
based on your last point of measure so
measure yourself daily measure your last
event mess in your lab Stephanie come up
with the systems and the accountability
to prove out how effective you've been
with you're talking perfection
perfecting the last miss production it's
a marketing term people don't know no
you didn't know support you if your
product is in quality they won by if
your excellence isn't repeated you also
see your demise if you fail to
accurately mention what you do no one
will help count on you you have to be
able to judge yourself before others
judging if you're affected the world
will know it and you will never have to
repeat it
this one piece I left out one point in
the blueprint
it's called Brad prayed a problem you
don't know how big it is how bad at this
how often in homes how grand it is to
keep repeating it so we counted in jail
we kind of in the streets the primary
County or County we're coming or County
pretty problem because there is a heaven
the preceding program was brought to you
by Teachers College Columbia University
please visit us online at iTunes tc
Columbia edu